what do you need to do on this day to
achieve your goal do you do it or not it
really is that cut and dry and if you're
looking over your shoulder for somebody
to save you I can tell you right now
they are not coming no one is coming to
help you people that don't give it about
what they're doing with their life is
terrifying and when you don't care about
what you're working on there's no
meaning or purpose behind the thing that
you're trying to do then of course it's
going to be harder to stay on track of
course you're going to be looking for
that dopamine hit from your phone from
that email because working on the thing
that you're working on doesn't give you
the dopamine hit if you want to be
successful mindset is everything the
reason that mindset is so important is
at the end of the day only execution
matters so if you have big dreams if you
have goals something that you're trying
to accomplish in your life you're going
to have to execute against that the
struggle is guaranteed the success is
not and like the thing that I beg you
guys is to have the guts to fail at
something that you love and when you
were on the mud on your face and people
are laughing the I told you cells are
coming out that you remember one simple
fact you loved what you were doing and
you left it out on the field what the
else is there need motivation watch
a top 10 with believe Nation hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because when I started my first business
I really struggled to believe myself I
was making 300 bucks a month and quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the stories of
successful entrepreneurs they gave me
strategies as well as hope and belief
that just maybe I could do it myself as
well and I hope that this video here
today helps you get a little bit more
belief in yourself because I still need
the videos for myself today too so today
listen from one of the best Tom bilyeu
and my take on his top 10 rules of
success
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one establish a routine learning
routines are one of the most important
things that you can create in your life
and the reason is when you start the day
if you get early momentum going the rest
of the day is often going to follow in
that it's an idea called entropy
everything moves towards chaos and the
only way to combat that is to put energy
into the system you are not going to
wake up and randomly have a good day
you're going to have to structure your
day in a way that sets you up to
overcome all of the entropy all of that
chaos all of the thousand things going
to come at you in a on a daily basis
that are going to knock you off course
and the easiest way to do that is to
have a routine that you follow every
morning so you don't have to think about
it you don't have to reinvent the wheel
you don't have to wonder or think about
what you should be doing it's just right
there it is baked into the routine so by
doing that now you can actually
accomplish the most important things
first so the thing to doing your morning
routine well is to optimize for what Tim
Ferriss refers to as the lead Domino
what's the thing that if I did this it's
going to make everything else easier
down the road so number one a morning
routine actually starts the night before
you want to get plenty of sleep why
because that's going to optimize your
your cognition the next thing you want
to do is either meditate or work out
typically I will work out first the
reason that I work out is because it
optimizes your cognition so that
everything else is going to get easier
it also dramatically impacts your energy
levels talk about two things that are
incredible lead dominoes if I'm getting
sleep and optimizing my cognition if I'm
working out and optimizing my cognition
and I am making sure that I have the
energy levels that I need to get things
done now I'm really making sure that
everything that I do after that is
easier the next thing that I do is
meditate why because it optimizes your
cognition you want to make sure that
you're getting all of your background
radiation the stress the anxiety you
want to get that as close to zero as you
can that way you can think clearly you
get into what I call a calm and creative
state so that area of your brain that
don't often communicate are able to
communicate get better ideas that way
again lead Domino improving your
cognition lowering your stress levels
making sure that you're centered and
that you've got that energy to move
forward then I'm going to go down my
list of important things I make that
list the day before so I know exactly
what I should be doing at any one time
and again it's a lead Domino strategy
what the first thing that I'm going to
do is going to be the thing that makes
everything else on my list easier I'm
going to do everything that I can do on
the most important thing and by the way
they should always be rank ordered there
is no such thing as a tie there is a
number one a number two a number three a
number four so on and so forth there's
not two number ones there's not two
number twos there was a one two three
four five so on and so forth I do
everything that I can do on number one
once that's now where I'm waiting for
something else or you know I just have
to let it bake whatever then I'm going
to move on to number two I'm gonna do
everything I can on number two then I'm
going to move on to number three do you
set your day up like that and you're not
checking your phone and you're not
responding to other people because
that's letting them control your
schedule and what are the odds that
somebody other than you knows better
what you should be doing to make your
goals come true than you the answer
should be zero because if somebody else
knows better than you we already have a
problem it means that somebody else is
paying more attention to your own life
than you are that would be problematic
get that morning routine down get that
momentum going do the lead Domino
strategy make sure you're optimizing for
energy and cognition absolutely critical
rule number two is push yourself once
you know what your goal is that goal
then makes demands and you either live
up to those demands or you don't and the
reality is that most people don't so
even when they have the clarity and they
get into it and their kids wake them up
in the middle of the night and then
they're really tired the next day they
wake up late they're rushing out of the
door to get to work they go their bosses
addict to them they come home they're
super stressed out through all of that
their goal suddenly becomes unimportant
and unfortunately because life is hard
and life is going to punch Us in the
face constantly over and over over the
only way that you're going to achieve
your goals is if in that moment you get
more aggressive that you have those
rules in your life that are like I am
doing this every day I know that I'm
trying to read X number of books lose X
number of pounds by this date and that
means by the end of this week I need to
have lost a pound or two pounds by the
end of the month I need to have lost
five pounds whatever your goal demands
your goal ultimately will be translated
into math so it is very simple what do
you need to do on this day to achieve
your goal do you do it or not it really
is that cut and dry and if you're
looking over your shoulder for somebody
to save you I can tell you right now
they are not coming no one is coming to
help you this is something that you have
to do for yourself and I hope in hearing
all of this you realize why 92 percent
of people fall into the category of I
gave up I quit I knew what my goal was
or I didn't have enough Clarity but I
didn't do the things that I needed to do
in order to cross the finish line it
really is that simple now the great news
is it really is that simple if you just
draw those bright lines in your life if
you make those demands of yourself if
you say I simply must do this to be the
person that I want to be and therefore
I'm going to do it even when it's hard
even when it sucks even when it's boring
I'm going to keep doing this and let me
tell you right now even though what I'm
talking about is achieving goals I
promise you one thing if you set a goal
and you achieve it you will gain respect
for yourself and there is nothing that
matters more and I mean nothing there is
nothing that matters more than how you
feel about yourself when you're by
yourself so if you structure your life
in a way where you set a goal that is
two things exciting and honorable
exciting to you you just want to do it
other people don't have to tell you to
do it you just want to do it right it
goes back to the whole thing you've got
to want it badly enough and if you want
it badly enough then you're going to
stick with it and if you don't then you
won't rule number three is eliminate
distractions the way that I found to
stay focused be productive and not get
distracted is one by auditing my time so
that I know one what I'm supposed to be
working on and then two that at the end
of any task I'm going to reflect back on
how long it took me how much time did I
spend on task and also I have rules like
if I'm working on something I don't take
out my phone I don't look at it no
matter what I have no alerts on my
computer no alerts on my phone if
somebody's calling I would never know if
somebody's texted me I would never know
I don't have anything that pops up on my
computer you want to eliminate
distractions I don't even work facing a
window I will go into a room and I will
intentionally face myself away from a
window there was one period of my life
the only reason I stopped doing this is
because I think it's really important to
get daylight in your eyes but I was
putting myself in a dark room and
literally with a stand-up desk was the
only thing between me and a wall so even
though I was in a nice expansive
beautiful room I was putting myself
facing the wall so that there was
nothing for me to even look at that I
want to be work working on the thing
that I'm trying to accomplish and the
other thing is that's hugely important
is to make sure that you care about what
you're working on the number of people
that don't give about what they're doing
with their life is terrifying and when
you don't care about what you're working
on there's no meaning or purpose behind
the thing that you're trying to do then
of course it's going to be harder to
stay on track of course you're going to
be looking for that dopamine hit from
your phone from that email because
working on the thing that you're working
on doesn't give you the dopamine hit
making sure that you're pursuing things
that you care about that's a huge part
of it rule number four is have a growth
mindset if you want to be successful
mindset is everything the reason that
mindset is so important is at the end of
the day only execution matters so if you
have big dreams if you have goals
something that you're trying to
accomplish in your life you're going to
have to execute against that so why do I
say that mindset is so important in that
scenario the reason is that ultimate
ultimately to achieve the things you
want to achieve I can promise you when
you start out you're not good enough yet
to achieve that and or you don't have
the right plan and so the way to refine
the plan to actually do the thing that
you want to accomplish you're going to
have to run through what I call the
physics of progress the physics of
progress are very simple they require
you to have a hypothesis which is simply
your best guess this is what I think I
have to do to achieve my goals then
you're going to turn that into something
you can do you're going to do that thing
it's going to fail to some degree that's
just the way it works but failure is the
most information Rich data stream on
planet Earth but to accurately assess
the data and figure out what it's
telling you about why you failed to some
extent or why it was more
inefficient than it needs to be
you have to be willing to stare nakedly
at your own inadequacies take
responsibility for the outcome not make
it somebody else's fault or the
economy's fault or whatever any external
Force if you're making it an external
problem you're never going to be able to
learn the lesson you need to learn in
order to improve your behavior so that
you can then execute better and make
more progress that really is it that's
the physics of progress hypothesis
turn it into something actionable run
that action learn from the partial
failure get a little bit smarter
come up with a new hypothesis that is
more informed turn it into something
actionable run that it will fail again
to some degree figure out why by
lowering your defenses having a growth
mindset making sure that you are able to
take on the responsibility now why is
that a mindset question why can't you
just run that equation if it really is
that simple the answer is you have in
your brain something called the
psychological immune system this is
something given to you by millions of
years of evolution we should all be
extremely grateful for it and the
psychological immune system's job is to
make sure that you don't commit suicide
it is designed to make you feel better
about things it's the reason why you can
mess up make a mistake and you can
soothe yourself now the problem is that
the goal of the psychological immune
system is not for you to achieve your
goals it's simply to make sure that you
feel good enough about yourself that you
can keep moving through life
now the reason that that becomes wildly
problematic and is one of the most
important things you have to address in
your mindset if you're going to be
successful is because the number one
tool that your psychological immune
system works to soothe your ego is to
make everything somebody else's fault it
is the fault of the government it is the
fault of rich people it is the fault of
not being born the right color not being
born the right sex so on and so forth it
is making something the external problem
now here's the really bad news your
psychological immune system is going to
grab for a very valid excuse those
things that I listed may all be true
they may really all be holding you back
the problem is you want to know what the
right mindset for success is and if you
want to be successful you are going to
have to overcome a endless parade of
problems and to overcome the endless
parade of problems you have to have a
way to take responsibility
for what you can do differently to
overcome those problems instead of being
annoyed instead of shutting down instead
of just pointing the finger you want to
adapt your behavior also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is set specific
goals the reason most people fail to
achieve their goals is twofold number
one they don't have a sufficient level
of clarity and number two they don't
want it badly enough the statistic is
that 92 of all people that said in New
Year's resolution failed to stick with
it the way that you go from being in the
92 percent to being in the eight percent
is by having a freakish level of clarity
and building so much desire in your life
that nothing could stop you even if it
tried this is what you need to do
the clarity piece is really the most
important thing that you can have in
your life and most people have a really
vague sense of clarity but because they
can say in a sense something like I'm
gonna win a gold medal they think they
have the clarity that they need but the
question I would ask somebody that told
me that they wanted to win a gold medal
is a gold medal in what the Olympics yes
Tom I want to win a gold medal in the
Olympics amazing which events swimming
or tennis swimming fantastic the
breaststroke the freestyle medley what's
it going to be you have to get so
specific with your goal that you know
what to do with the next 15 minutes of
your life ultimately success
accomplishing a goal seeing things
through all come down to what you're
doing with your time and what part of
your potential you're turning into
actual usable skill set the only way to
know how to spend your time transferring
your potential into skill set that is to
have a truly granular level of clarity
you cannot stop at the high level and
you can't do what a lot of people do
which is they as the Brits say they
waffle so when they're describing their
goal they either say something like I
want to win a gold medal which we just
covered is hopelessly vague or they say
something that's even worse which is you
know I really want to do something great
with my life I know that I'm capable you
know I was really athletic when I was a
kid and I know that if I applied myself
I could probably really you know
recapture what I was doing that's how
most people describe what they want to
do in life it is terrifying you need to
be able to State what your goal is in a
single sentence with no commas
parentheticals run-ons it needs to be a
very simple and direct goal something
like I'm going to win a gold medal in
the Summer Olympics freestyle medley
swimming event by 2028 whatever once you
have a go goal that is that specific
that contains the what you're going to
do the by when and how much then you
know that you actually have a real goal
and not a hope not a vague idea but you
have something very concrete and
specific that you can execute against
now remember the goal is to translate
that into what you're going to do with
the next 15 minutes of your life always
and forever on and on and on when you
have something so specific that you know
how to break it down into those
incremental steps you can really begin
to make progress if you've ever heard
the idea of the 10 000 hour principle
it's talking about how we go about
actually achieving Mastery in something
and the punch line is that you spend ten
thousand hours applying yourself in a
disciplined fashion towards your goal
the discipline fashion is born out of
the clarity it's born out of the clarity
of knowing precisely what you're trying
to achieve and by when and knowing how
how to take advantage of I've tried
something it didn't quite work I need to
get a little bit better or this part of
my game is weak I need to focus on
getting better at that thing but again
all of that is born from clarity
and being able to break down that
Clarity into action items which is
absolutely critical because action items
are how we're going to turn our
potential into skill set and that is the
critical chain that you have to walk
rule number six is have the guts to fail
I'm afraid of getting to the end of my
life
and realizing that I did not
that I got to the very end of my life
and I did not accomplish every single
thing I know I believe in my heart that
I deserve to have
I know the only thing that's stopping me
is myself
I love that I think that's the right
fear and I think all of us should have
some form of that fear which if you
didn't hear is to have a vision of the
person you could become
and to reach the Pearly Gates as it were
see who you could have been contrasted
with who you actually are and be
disappointed by the gap between them
and I love chasing that I think it's a
beautiful Chase
but what I hope you guys will do if you
ever find yourself at the Pearly Gates
disappointed in how much farther you
could have gone
to Simply ask one question of yourself
every day
did I give it my all today
doesn't mean you're always going to win
yeah
if your life is a series of
yes I did
You've Won
You've Won guys the struggle is
guaranteed the struggle is guaranteed
the struggle is guaranteed the success
is not
and like the thing that I beg you guys
is to have the guts to fail at something
that you love
and when you were on the mud on your
face and people are laughing I told you
souls are coming out
that you remember one simple fact
you loved what you were doing
and you left it out on the field what
the else is there
legitimately like I'm getting emotional
what the else is there what more
can you ask of yourself than to really
try to really say I give a about
this
that's the life to live that's the life
like to say I care about this it matters
it gives me purpose I'm gonna fight for
this this is a group of people I want to
serve
and I'm gonna go all the way out every
day and look you're not going to hit it
every day there's going to be days where
you're off there's going to be days
where you're weak
weak but if that day instead of bull
yourself instead of saying I wasn't weak
today what are you talking about if that
day you own it and you say yeah
I was weak today and I'm not going to be
weak tomorrow but I'm not afraid to face
that I'm not afraid to accept that I'm
not perfect I'm not afraid to look in
the mirror and say today was a bad day
that I didn't make myself proud today
but that shouldn't diminish who you are
it shouldn't diminish your view of
yourself why because I wouldn't serve
you
because if you beat yourself up today
you make it harder for you to be rad
tomorrow
it's a game that has to be seen in total
it's not a game where you can take a
snapshot and this is like what I
want you guys to understand in any one
moment I've looked like a fool so many
times I can't count
but when I look at my life in 10-year
chunks I'm freaked out by what I've
accomplished rule number seven is build
desire I was diagnosed with ADH sorry I
was diagnosed with hyperactivity
disorder when I was a kid that would
almost certainly translate today into a
diagnosis of ADHD so
I really struggle to stay on task so
this is something I've had to put a lot
of rules around in my life
so
because I distrust myself when I have
the impulse to do something I ask myself
is this actually going to move me
towards my goal yes or no if it moves me
towards my goal then I'm going to do it
but I also know that I'm prone to lie to
myself so oh would looking at Tick Tock
right now move me towards my goal of
course I would I need to master the
algorithm 100 I should look okay wait
you're prone to lie to yourself so did
you make a list of the important things
you should be doing yes do you have a
calendar that tells you what you should
be doing right now yes so like in my
calendar I have a time that says
important things it's a free-form thing
so it's the moment where I'm most likely
to get myself in trouble because I'm not
doing the things that I should be so I
keep a list of important things that are
listed in order of what I need to
execute against so I'm goal obsessed
and to get goal obsessed I built desire
to build desire you do the following you
need to say internally this is my goal
and I'm obsessed
now hopefully that hits everyone
listening to this is stupid so basic
that it cannot be true but it
really is true you become what you
repeat so I tell myself this is my goal
and I'm obsessed
then I tell other people this is my goal
I'm obsessed I'm building the next
Disney for me say that a couple times so
and I'm obsessed with Disney okay that's
the first part but it's not going to get
you very far but if I do this
yo I'm gonna build the next Disney and
let me tell you why I'm gonna build the
next Disney because I used to Big
Brother for this little kid and I
watched the ZIP code Edom did you guys
know for real this is actually true
right now in the entire Western World
your ZIP code is the number one
predictor of your future success now
what I'm doing is embodying the way that
I want to feel at the beginning people
need to understand in the beginning it
felt fake to me because I was walking
myself through the process of building
desire I was saying it internally I was
saying it externally and I was embodying
the thing I wanted to feel
when I said it
the way that the brain works it will
justify whatever you do
it's one of the worst things about the
brain it's amazing because of the
psychological immune system but the
psychological immune system's job is to
keep you from committing suicide it is
not to help you get ahead in life
unfortunately
so your psychological immune system is
going to come up with a justification
for why you do whatever you do you can
actually there's a study done on this
with patients that have an inability to
term short-term memory into long-term
memory so you can re-meet them every
three minutes and they will not remember
meeting you so a doctor will walk in
they will put a pin in his hand he
shakes your hand it pokes you it hurts
you come back three minutes later you
don't remember meeting the doctor he
extends his hand to shake your hand and
the person with the selective or the
memory damage won't shake his hand
so you ask why won't you shake my hand
oh I don't like to shake the hand of
people in white lab coats oh I don't
shake the hands of doctors oh my
shoulder's hurting today I just don't
feel like shaking hands they're all lies
but the person doesn't realize that
they're lying now once you understand
it's easy you want to be with that
person and just be like oh well they
have brain damage of course they do that
no no we all do that so once you
understand you have all these weird
things happening in your brain and one
of them is that it's going to make up an
excuse a justification for whatever you
do you can now leverage that so as I
tell people yo I'm really hyped about
the saying and it's because of your zip
code and like I really think that I can
help people get an empowering mindset
through story at scale they're going to
escape their zip code it's going to be
amazing makes me feel the way that I
want to feel I'm going to be able to
contribute this is amazing
now all of a sudden six months into that
repetition cycle I actually started
feeling it and it wasn't fake anymore
and I actually felt that like high level
of energy every time I would go to
explain it to people rule number eight
is control your emotions change the
dynamic of the way that you're thinking
so that you don't get trapped in your
own neurochemistry because when you have
an emotion
the chances are you believe that emotion
but the brain has this crazy weird
mechanism where however big you react it
goes oh it was that big of a deal so if
you freak the out and you're
yelling and screaming then your brain's
like yeah man it really it matters that
much like I said no cheese on this
hamburger
cheese on this burger
that is crazy you you can't do that
you can't put
get the flavor it says no cheese and
when you wind yourself up like that then
literally it just gets hardwired that
yeah this really is that catastrophic
but the reverse is true something
horrifying happens something terrible
goes wrong and if you can in your mind
just flip it and be like yeah we're
gonna figure this out rule number nine
is build good habits how do you stay
focused in this world full of
distractions I often find myself
procrastinating and watching YouTube
videos forever alright so this really
does come down to habits and routines
this is one of those things I cannot
stress enough if you haven't built in
mechanisms to deal with your lesser
nature you're forever gonna fall prey to
them some of it is identity some of it
is I'm the kind of person who makes use
of my time some of it is I'm the kind of
person that has goals and I do that
which moves me towards my goals but then
some of it is reinforcing that belief
with very strict rules what I'll call
Bright lines so some of my bright lines
are I go to bed at 9pm period second
bright line I only have 10 minutes to
get out of bed so I wake up when I wake
up I don't use an alarm but once I
realize I'm awake then I only have 10
minutes to get out of bed as long as
I've had at least five hours so look at
the clock see what time it is I have 10
minutes boom I'm up and I emotionally
reward myself when I meet the deadline
and I emotionally punish myself if I
miss it and when I miss it by the way
it's usually by seconds it's not like
ever I'm just like it and I stay in
bed for 20 minutes that would not be a
bright line so but hard and fast 10
minutes emotionally reward yourself or
emotionally punish yourself whether you
do it or not and then just having a
compelling future it is so critical that
you have a compelling future that
there's actually something that you're
excited about and this makes me think of
Weekend Warriors for most people no one
has to tell you what to do on the
weekend you're very excited to do it you
get out of bed with some enthusiasm
there's something that you want to do
that day even if it's play video games
read watch a movie hang out with your
significant other whatever it is there
is something that you're excited about
and there is a way and I won't answer it
in this question but there is a way to
put at the center of your life and all
the things you're doing to work and to
build something to put that thing that
you enjoy at the center of that so that
you're generating income off of
something that you love doing that is
very very possible I'm gonna pretend the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is Chase fulfillment here's the
thing about happiness happiness is by
nature transient happiness is also a
neurochemical state
and for me to get out from under my
brain I finally had to understand that
neurochemistry
[Music]
is fickle and it changes from one minute
to the next in fact who's ever had a day
in the same day where you thought
I'm so amazing like this is crazy for
real are other people this good at
anything like I'm just and then I'm not
joking 40 minutes later you're like oh
and I am I can't believe I'm
never gonna succeed like this is a joke
I am a total piece of who's ever
been there
foreign
that's essentially Universal hands in
the air so just know the next time that
you have one of those down moments
remember everybody else is feeling that
the joke is on all of us we're all
feeling it but we think we're the only
ones so we hide it so we get in these
Loops about happiness look happiness
comes and goes it's super transient
you're gonna feel it one minute you're
not gonna feel it the next that is the
nature of things
burn that notion into your head that is
the nature of things all right well if I
know that it's there if I know that it's
predictable then I'm not going to Let It
Whip me into a frenzy I know
that as I'm sure Mr J Shetty would say
this too shall pass
learn that phrase and learn it well this
too shall pass
the highs will pass the lows will pass
so don't focus on happiness it's too
transient
focus on fulfillment
fulfillment is defined very simply you
work very hard for a set of skills that
have meaning to you you care about them
in and of themselves and those skills
that you have worked so hard to obtain
they allow you to serve not only
yourself but others
that's the key to making this highly
Social Animal fulfilled and to have
something that sustains over time
fulfillment is born of suffering it's
born of doing the hard things so even in
those dark moments you can see beauty
you can experience the joy of being
alive you can experience the joy of
having loved ones because it endures
fulfillment endures
there is a metric ton of uncertainty
right now there's no two ways about that
but you get to control how you spend
your time so when you think about making
the most of this time if you allow
yourself to get overwhelmed by the
uncertainty then
you're going to be paralyzed and you're
not going to make good use of this time
versus if you know what you want to be
accomplishing you know exactly what your
goal is you know hey six months from now
I want to be doing this a year from now
I want to be doing this whatever you
can't control what happens to the world
so literally shut that out of your mind
build the skill set that you want to
build that allows you to do the things
you want to do
at the end of six months a year 18
months two years whatever that is
however far out that you're looking
skills have utility decide what that
skill set is and now we're going to
spend the time building that because
that is something that we can control we
can go in and we can get good at that
thing now when you're on in the process
of getting good hitting plateaus is
absolutely unavoidable what you want to
do is figure out what is it that's
beginning to break down so if you're a
violinist what is it do you have a hard
time reading music cold reading do you
have a hard time with the finger
positioning do you have a hard time with
changing tempos like whatever is the
weakness that makes you feel like you've
plateaued you have to identify what the
difference is between where you are and
where you want to be now oftentimes as
identifying somebody who's better than
you and saying why are they better than
me and not like in a judgment about
their Worth or anything like that just
what is it that they do better than me
and then begin to dissect it look there
is quite literally much to my dismay
nothing that as of today I'm the best in
the world at now uh drives me crazy when
people do this sure I could sub segment
things far down enough to say that you
know I'm the best person recording
podcast answers from the hours of 4 pm
to 407 PM in the zip code you know of
whatever
sure but as of right now at a macro
level there is nothing that I am trying
to be the best at that I'm actually the
best at but I don't let it damage my
self-esteem to stare nakedly at my
inadequacies because my self-esteem is
built around entirely being the learner
acknowledging where I'm lacking right
lacking in the sense of there's a gap
between where I am and where I want to
be that's the lack self-defined and I'm
willing to stare nakedly at that and say
cool this person up here is better than
me I want to beat them I want to get
better than them but I also need to
acknowledge what they're better than me
at now can I just get better than them
at that thing do I need to find a
separate thing for me to get good at
right so if I were trying to play
basketball I'm not going to try to beat
LeBron James in a one-on-one he has
physical attributes that I think it
would be next to impossible for me to
counter directly but there are other
things that I might be able to get good
at I might be able to read the court
better I might be better at passing who
knows but you go and identify given the
50 of me that's hardwired that I can't
change and the 50 of me that is
malleable how do I bring the reality of
those two things together in a way that
allows me to perform at the level that I
want so you've identified what it is
you're underperforming at and now you're
going to go into deliberate practice so
there's a book by Anders Erickson called
peak in that book he breaks down the
process of deliberate practice of how
you take the things that you're not good
at not the things you already are good
at which is what most people will tell
you lean into your strengths that's some
you yes know what your
strengths are yes leverage them whenever
you're in a performance situation and
you have to outperform but when we're
talking about practice
we don't want to lean into the things
that we already do well we want to
systematically
break out the things that we're not good
at and find a way to do a a practice
cycle a repetition cycle that allows us
to actually get better this is not blind
repetition this is strategic repetition
designed to give a desired outcome
whether it's being able to reach music
faster you're gonna have to be able to
measure this stuff so figuring out what
it is finding a way to measure it
finding a way to break down the practice
elements into steps so that you get
better at one small thing which stacks
on another small thing which stacks on
another small thing until you're
actually bringing all of these small
things that you have practiced
religiously diligently deliberately to
get better and now when you go back to
perform again you're able to perform at
a higher level so not accepting a
plateau is a big part of it not thinking
well when I've hit this Plateau that
just is what it is and I've reached the
limits I can pretty much assure you
nobody is ever going to reach the limits
of their capabilities before they die
there just isn't enough time so
breaking it down into the smaller pieces
that stack practicing the things you're
bad at grouping it back together and
then going out to perform and not
letting yourself get overwhelmed by the
uncertainty that is the answer
fulfillment is very simple for me so and
it has to do with the directives that
are embedded in your brain from an
evolutionary standpoint so you must work
hard it's embedded in your brain to
acquire skills that matter to you that
allow you to elevate yourself and others
in service of a goal that's both
exciting and honorable
so exciting and honorable means that
you're just amped about it you dig it so
I dig storytelling just I do and I want
to help people through storytelling I do
my life circumstances have led me to
that the way that I'm hardwired I just
have an over
um an outsized response to stories and
so I'm drawn to that and because of life
experience I want to use stories to help
people so that's very exciting for me
now it's also honorable because I'm not
just looking to make myself rich or be
admired for telling a cool story I
actually want to help people with that
story and I hold myself accountable to
that so when you have that cocktail
you're working hard to Garner a set of
skills that allow you to serve not only
yourself but other people it that's
fulfillment so people can say whatever
they want and I know like if I'm
actually out there every day doing my
best to help people I'm going to feel
good about that now I'm not going to
feel good about people misunderstanding
that that's still going to suck but I
know it's in my heart and so if I'm like
no for real I'm showing up no matter
what people say I really am showing up
to help people then that will give you
the emotional resilience that you need
to see yourself through so fulfillment
is
it's able to withstand even moments of
unhappiness and when you have
fulfillment the thing that you believe
in that you're fighting for then it gets
easier to push through you know whatever
frustrations difficulties the mob coming
after you whatever if you don't have
that and it was you were just trying to
be famous or get approval and it feels
like the entire world is piling on you
you just are like yeah I'm done with
this so there really has to be something
you're fighting for I can't rule out
that you may be in a toxic environment
so let's just say if you're in a toxic
environment that's a real thing you want
to get out of that toxic environment you
want to move on to something else like
that just trying to change a whole
organization if they are toxic is not
interesting to me in the slightest now
toxicity comes from insecurity so if
that helps it actually does help me to
know that when people are
um
mean-spirited when they like to see
other people fail it's all coming from
their own insecurities I find tremendous
emotional relief in that uh
now I want to talk about being low
in a non-toxic environment
while I don't think anybody races to
have others witness them at their worst
we've all been there we are all deeply
flawed emotional creatures and
showing vulnerability
should never be frowned on for you
forget how people are reacting right so
there's wallowing
and that is an interesting
shouldn't be interesting to you and
yourself or in others there is
wanting sympathy instead of empathy
so sympathy is
feel bad for me
you should never want that empathy is
understand where I'm at
being seen is rad
and my wife and I have an agreement
I don't want sympathy from her no matter
how hard my life gets empathy
desperately
and the way that we've always explained
it to each other is if I'm ever knocked
to my knees
I don't want you to get on your knees
with me and cry
I want you to extend a hand
tell me how much you love me
pick me back up brush me off and remind
me of who I can become
that's rad
so I'm not worried if she sees me low
I'm not worried if my team sees me fail
um I think all of us if you're really
going for something extraordinary I
think all of us are going to fail at
least as much as we succeed maybe more
and so fearing the low moments is not
the right way to think about it
re-contextualize that failure as a
learning opportunity earn people's
respect not command it earn people's
Respect by getting back up on your feet
not asking people to feel bad for you
focusing on the learning opportunity
show that you have a growth mindset get
your ego out of the way
Focus entirely on getting better
and if you rebound quickly
with energy and enthusiasm
even if some people take the opportunity
to kick you while you're down
in the long run people will gravitate
towards you because they see that you're
real you're not posing they see that you
bounce back that you don't whine wallow
complain you get up you're focused on
Improvement and moving forward and look
the reality is getting great requires
you to fail over and over and over
there's an amazing quote by Winston
Churchill and he says success is the
ability to go from failure to failure to
failure without a loss of enthusiasm
and you just can't worry about what
other people are thinking when you're
down you have to go cool this is a
learning experience I'm going to get
back up and your response to that
shouldn't be orchestrated to command
respect earn respect to even think about
people it should be you have a goal
and you know to build your skill set to
the point
where you're so good that you can't be
denied that all the Blues in the world
can't block your dunk you have to fail
because it really it it really is it
isn't a saying failure is the most
information Rich data stream you will
ever encounter in the failure if you get
your ego out of the way and you're not
crying about it and you're not you know
worried about what other people are
going to think you're just thinking okay
cool I failed and if I can understand
why then I can get better
now you do that day in and day out all
of a sudden you're going to earn respect
as as a consequence of you're just
consistent Improvement
and if I were going to sum up everything
that we've talked about today it's that
it's
not focusing on earning people's respect
or worrying about what they think it's
about
the physics of how the world works and
the physics of how the world works
pretty straightforward
you have a goal you have an idea of how
to reach that goal right there's an
impediment between where you are and
where you want to be you've got a theory
about how to overcome that impediment
you try it many of the things you try
will fail or they'll be insufficient
you'll assess why it was insufficient
and you'll begin again more
intelligently as Henry Ford said failure
is just the ability to Begin Again more
intelligently and you do that over and
over and over and over and over and it's
what I call the physics of progress it
it's just you can't boil it down any
more simple than that
all right so don't be afraid of your low
moments if you're in a toxic environment
get out focus every day on getting
better and the respect will come as a
result of that have very clear goals it
always freaks me out most people stop at
the first sort of vague notion of what
they want to do I'm going to punch
myself in the mouth if somebody comes up
to me again and says I want to help
people
that's rad that comes from a beautiful
place like I totally get it but that's
like coming to me and saying I want to
win an Olympic gold medal awesome winter
or summer
fantastic swimming or tennis
swimming excellent
backstroke freestyle like at some point
it's got to get so specific because you
have to know what skills you need to
acquire you have to work backwards from
the goal and the goal has to be hyper
specific so if boredom is the number one
killer of entrepreneurs that they're not
able to make it through the next one is
they don't have clear goals and the
worst part is they think they do
that's the part that terrifies me the
until you know exactly what your mission
is and exactly what your business model
is and what problem you solve what very
concrete problem that people are
freaking out to have solved until you do
that you don't have the necessary
ingredients to build your business all
right don't be romantic be pragmatic
look at the data the data will tell you
what to kill the data will tell you
what's working and what's not
this was the single best piece of advice
that was ever given to me and I ignored
it for three years I'm so embarrassed by
that that I always make sure any talk I
give people hear this
know more about your product service
industry whatever than anyone else
than anyone else
if you guys have ever seen my interview
show
the reason that it's doing as well as
it's doing is I know more about the
guest one guest actually said this I
know more about the guest than their
mother
I just put in more work than their
that's the truth
I go out and I research and I read
everything and I watch every video that
I can and so I know so much about that
person I know I'm going to give a
different interview than anyone has ever
given before because nobody's done that
level of research not only does it Blow
the guest away and totally endear them
to me
but it gets us to the point where we can
give an interview that has unique value
so know more about what you're doing
than anyone else in the world and grind
baby grind for two years for two years
that's what I look like every day hair
net lab coat gloves
put in the work
put in the work and this is where the
rubber meets the road this is where
you're really going to separate the
people that are entrepreneurs from the
people that are real entrepreneurs
you've got to want to grind you've got
to learn to love that you've got to
learn to love to put in the work to be
proud of yourself that you showed up and
put in the work to be proud of yourself
that you taught yourself how to suffer
to be proud of yourself that you're
developing a mindset where you believe I
can do anything I set my mind to and by
the way
once you believe
that you could do anything you set your
mind to without limitation how you spend
your time
becomes a spiritual consideration
how you spend your time becomes a
spiritual consideration because you
could be doing something if you want to
end Hunger and hunger what's stopping
you Bill Gates is actually going to end
malaria he's going to do it because he
had the tenacity to generate the
resources and because he has a mind that
allows him to work on the infrastructure
and figure out how to actually solve
that problem do not under any
circumstances make Bill Gates or anyone
else extraordinary to let yourself off
the hook
don't do it don't sell yourself short
and this is where I see people go wrong
all the time they look at somebody who's
amazing
and they say Well they're just naturally
gifted
I could never do that
you couldn't do it because you believe
you can't and because you believe you
can't you don't start putting in the
work
Michael Jordan got cut from his high
school basketball team
he wasn't exactly showing all the
promise in the world my own mother when
I left for college quietly assumed I was
going to fail and didn't admit that for
years
I showed no early signs of promise
I actually have a version of this talk
where I show photos from my childhood
and people like yeah you just look
stupid
and it's true I used to dress like a
clown and I mean that almost literally
so my waist was size 36 and I wore a
size 54 pants
I wore literal Jester hats I had one of
those big chains that connected to my
belt uh I had shoulder length hair I did
not exactly look the part and I didn't
take myself seriously
it really is a game of transformation it
really is a game of understanding that
you can become something so even though
I didn't start with the requisite skills
even though I wasn't a born entrepreneur
which is why I start this tale with that
I could acquire and did acquire the
skills that were needed to execute
it is a very long road
that leads you here
right now
most entrepreneurs in the world are
thinking about one thing
winning a championship ring that's an
incredible question this is something
that I have lived through so when Quest
was small it was very easy for me to do
what I was saying at the top lead by
example I was there on the production
line I would take the hardest job and we
would literally agree what is the
hardest job this is the hardest job cool
if this is the hardest job I'm going to
be the one that that's going to do it
and I would get in there and I would do
it with all my might and Not only would
I do it but I would uplift other people
I would bring energy and enthusiasm and
I'm an introvert by Nature let me tell
you right now now In fairness I have a
pretty easy time going to extroverted so
my default though is introverted Now by
going on the line by encouraging other
people by taking the hard job all of a
sudden it was very easy for me to get
people to Rally behind me but as we
scaled the company now all of a sudden
there were a ton of people that had
never seen me
working like that so to them I was
almost a mythological figure by that
point I was creating YouTube content so
you know we had 3 000 employees many of
them had never met me
and so to them you know it was like oh
my God that's the guy that runs a
company or the guy that's on YouTube
whatever and it had a really problematic
effect on the way that they approached
me and so what I began to realize is you
have to have a culture you have to show
people up close what gets results
intoxicate them with certainty okay
that's a huge part if you really want to
take your leadership game to the next
level you want to make sure you know
exactly what needs to be done so within
the world of influence you're trying to
have you know where you're trying to go
so you have a goal very clear goal you
can articulate that goal this is where
we're going and then you never
and I mean never
let somebody outwork you and when you
have certainty on where you're going you
tell other people what that is we're
going to go after this most people live
their entire lives doubting themselves
doubting the path that they're going on
and even when you know and some element
of what I'm saying isn't going to work
out but you believe to the core of your
being I'll adjust I'll figure it out now
you can intoxicate people with certainty
and just go like a bat out of hell
towards that thing working in a way that
nobody else is going to match and if
when you do that you elevate those
around you rather than say hey why are
you losers not working as hard as me you
say hey we're a team I want to lift you
up I want to help you I want to help you
get there okay so now you establish that
with those around you in that near group
you make that the culture this is how we
move here this is what we're about so
you're as good as what you can write
down so you write down what that culture
is you let people know what it means to
be a part of this team
then when they get in you're encouraging
them you're elevating them
you start with the people closest to you
because you're you've been able to write
the culture down you know which way they
have to act you hold them accountable
you ask them to hold you accountable
right you're not trying to be above this
you're trying to be in it trying to show
people what it means so now you've got
your core group then they're going to
have their Core group and then that Core
group is going to have their Core group
and now that influence goes down so you
definitely have to set the example but
when you scale you have got
you have got
to get people to understand what the
culture is
get them to lead by example get them to
intoxicate people with certainty get
them to
show people what it means to have a goal
and to go after it and to live up to the
standards of that culture and now when
you elevate people and you're lifting
them up and you're not trying to beat
them down
then you get something really really
incredible then people will follow you
because it's a game of elevation it's a
game of skill acquisition it's a game of
goal accomplishment it's not
you're not wasting people's time you're
really making progress and progress is
one of the most foundational pillars of
human happiness the thing that I love is
that you're using the word build because
that's exactly what we're going to be
doing here you're going to construct
what you want your life to be you're
going to break it up into different
hours and segments so you know when it's
go time and then you're going to build
rules into your life that mandate that
you show up during those times so I have
a whole host of rules in my life they
can be small simple rules like I get out
of bed in 10 minutes or less they can be
more profound and impactful goals or
excuse me rules and I have a rule in my
life where Monday through Friday if I'm
awake I'm either working or working out
so if I were doing something like you in
this situation I would say okay these
two day two hours or five hours however
much time it is that you want to
allocate to the business you're gonna
say I am working on the business during
these times I'm going to tell myself I'm
going to tell other people that way
there's accountability then I'm going to
score myself at the end of that session
did I show up did I start when I said I
was going to start did I go hard the
whole time and I'm just going to give
myself a rating every day depending on
where I'm going how I did that day was I
distracted did I have flow was it a
great day a bad day and by doing that
I'm going to hold myself accountable so
I can see over time that I show up when
I said I was going to show up what was
the score that I gave myself for staying
focused staying on task and getting
things done and then the third thing to
really make this stick
you've got to find a way to be excited
about what you're doing and oftentimes
when people come and they say that
they're having trouble making a new
habit stick the reality is they just
don't want it badly enough and when you
realize that that's not an indictment on
you as a person that's a simple
statement about the fact that desire is
a process so you don't there's very few
things in your life that you just sort
of automatically are excited about most
of things if you really want to kick ass
at something you've got to build a ton
of energy into getting excited about
that thing now that comes in a couple
different forms number one is your why
why are you doing this so it might be
hey my husband and I were really excited
about this this is going to be our path
to freedom and building something with
him like this means everything to me and
I couldn't be more excited more honored
to be working side by side with my
husband to build something to show each
other what we're capable of to take care
of each other to you know give ourselves
what we need to build a family whatever
you're going to make that why you're
gonna say it you're going to say it with
enthusiasm it's what I call embodying
what you want to feel so if you want to
be excited when you're telling other
people when you're even talking to
yourself when you're talking to your
husband you're actually going to let
yourself get hyped up there's a
mechanism in the brain that says whoa
hey we're all hyped up about this it
must actually be worth being hyped up
about and it becomes a self-reinforcing
loop so we've got our why and then we
want to make sure that we're putting the
identity into it that we want to get out
so if we want to be the kind of person
that shows up and works hard then we say
I'm the type of person that shows up and
works hard and you're going to lean into
that and the why that you have with your
husband you guys are building something
you're excited about it you're telling
other people you're embodying it and now
you've got the identity statement if I'm
the type of person that does this I see
this through and you repeat that
cocktail over and over over and over and
following it up with that score and all
of a sudden over time and it will take
time because it is a process but over
time you're going to stick to it because
it means something to you and your
husband you've got the rule about
showing up you're rating yourself on how
you did that day you're feeling good on
the days you killed it and you're
reminding yourself to dig a Little
Deeper on the days where you don't and I
promise if you just work that process
over and over and over two weeks a month
into this it's just going to be second
nature you're going to be showing up
you're going to be excited you're going
to see it through because most people
hit a gazillion emotional snags as they
go through this they derail themselves
they don't listen to the truth of their
failure they don't want to own it
because it sucks EV every time Omar that
I realize that I have screwed up that
I'm wrong it sucks I don't enjoy it but
the thing that keeps me going is
recognizing that that is the nature of
progress itself and that if I fail to
look at what I can control that I could
do differently next time I'm either
going to repeat the mistake or I'm gonna
quit now the bad news about success is
it's a game of attrition and the really
bad news is that to move forward you
must be willing to fail a lot because
failure is the most information Rich
data stream that exists because it hurts
and you actually tried something so you
tried something there's real world
results those results hurt that pain
triggers the areas of the brain that
have to do with memory and focus so you
really look at that thing right this
again this is nature saying hey because
there's so much information in this
failure I want to make sure that we do
the things that get you to learn from
that so that the next time it is in a
close call with a tiger right that
either you can really keep distance
you're not putting yourself in that kind
of dangerous situation again and then
obviously the people that really got
themselves in trouble just got eaten and
so they're all wiped out and so that
becomes this Loop but every time you
fail you get this aversion response
where you don't want to do this again
you don't want to look at it you don't
want to face your inadequacies right and
it's really rough and then it's
magnified a thousand fold by social
media because now a thousand people are
telling you that you're a so it's
it is this really team and money and
time and energy and yeah you you magnify
that a million fold because now there's
a lot at stake for a lot of different
people and so most people they just
can't keep iterating and so it's um
it is the game and there's as far as I
can tell and look I'm constantly
updating my mental models but as far as
I can tell that's the ground floor that
that really is the physics of progress
and if you can't figure out that when I
just failed I'm gonna fail publicly and
people were making fun of me in that
moment can I just stay centered or get
centered again because of course you're
going to get knocked off can I re-center
myself very quickly and focus on what I
need to do and once the do is back to
hypothesis back to execution and if you
can stay in that Loop what do I need to
do what's the next thing to try then on
a long enough timeline you can win but
most people they just stop man it's just
too much it's not fun and by the way
there is a a ready-made off-ramp because
I don't know how many people should
listen to me I don't know how many
people should live the kind of life that
I'm trying to live where I'm trying to
have outside success I'm trying to build
something massive
um
for the right person I think that I
actually have the right tools like these
have served me incredibly well in my
life I have the receipts to show that it
works but I also have the receipts to
show emotionally it's brutal and if you
don't know how to rebalance yourself
it's not a winning proposition so
focusing on that the mental game of like
fulfillment matters fulfillment it's
important Joy is a metric optimize your
life for joy and then you've got to play
the game on a really long timeline so
you have to Discount anybody that says
you know you're a for this failure
it's like that isn't that doesn't ring
true to me for the following reason
making a mistake and even doing
something that is objectively stupid
let's say that the vast majority of
humanity would would have seen clearly
that which I missed okay so let's say
that that was true and I'll qualify that
and say that's what we're defining as
stupid so let's say that I actually do
make a stupid mistake that most people
would not have made
if in that moment I give up I'm out of
the game if in that moment I can
re-center learn my lesson and keep going
then I just I put myself in a in an
Elite Class not because I you know can
prognosticate everything accurately but
because I don't quit and that's really
been my secret is I just don't give up
one of the things I think people don't
understand about being a CEO is that
ultimately being a CEO running a company
is almost I mean it's it's 70 percent
people I mean the strategy is definitely
important but man momentum isn't about
moving fast or I should say it isn't
just about moving fast it's about
getting a group of people pointed in the
same direction and moving fast and so
understanding how to Galvanize a team
and get them pointed in the same
direction is really really critical so
in this specific time number one is
leading by example always and forever if
you want to do anything when people are
involved whether it's kids whether it's
somebody you love that is
um there's a piece of advice you
definitely that desperately want them to
take and they're not taking it whether
it's your company the answer is always
first and foremost lead by example that
is critically important so you want to
be hopeful you want to be optimistic you
want to show them through your behaviors
and your actions time and time again
with an inhuman level of consistency
exactly how to fail base adversity now
you don't want to you don't
want to lie so you want to make sure
that you're doing the work to make sure
that you're keeping yourself hopeful and
optimistic now how do we stay hopeful
and optimistic we have to have certain
beliefs in place and we have to have
certain rules in place so first of all
as it comes to rules I know that I
always need to be moving forward I can
never be afraid to make a decision that
I would rather be running a thousand
miles an hour in the wrong direction
than standing still okay that rule has
served me very well now why is it better
Tom you're running in the wrong
direction that's way worse than standing
still
not true the reason that you never want
to stand still is there's zero progress
made when you stand still when you move
you're at least learning even if you're
moving in the wrong direction failure is
the most information Rich data stream
you will ever encounter let me say that
again
failure moving in the wrong direction is
the most information Rich data stream
you will ever encounter meaning you're
going to learn a lot so now when you
turn around and you start moving in the
right direction you're making a huge
amount of progress so even though yes
you have to backtrack it's still far
better than standing still and not
learning those lessons so that is huge
so you have that rule now beliefs you
need to believe that if it doesn't
violate the laws of physics then you can
solve the problem what happens is most
people stay in this Frame of Mind where
all they can see are the problems and
right now there is an avalanche of
problems it is so easy to get mired in
the problems
but if you have a belief that as long as
it doesn't violate the laws of physics
this is possible that any obstacle can
be overcome that you just have to figure
out what it is that's going to allow you
to go over this obstacle under this
obstacle through this obstacle around
this obstacle whatever but you know that
giving up is not an option now it's like
cool hey even if I fail even if I mess
up I'm going to learn so there's some
hope there's some optimism right you can
meet your team with a truism something
that you actually believe you can use
Jocko willing's language which he says
anytime something goes wrong his only
response is good the enemy is bearing
down on us good we don't have enough
equipment good and because he meets it
with that he stays in a solution
oriented mindset now you always want to
be in a solution-oriented mindset when
all you're doing is focusing on the
problems and the most Sinister thing
about excuses is how valid they are so I
get it you have every excuse in the book
for things to fail to not be optimistic
to not be hopeful I get it and it's all
real we are going through the most most
devastating time for a business ever
and how do I respond to that good
because I know in this there's going to
be a solution and I'm going to figure it
out where a lot of people are going to
break because they're not going to be
able to get their head in the right
place so my team can see that I'm
hopeful I'm optimistic because I have
that belief because I have the rule to
be moving forward to figure this out to
not be afraid to fail and they see me
with that like almost naive optimism
always moving forward but they also see
me learning from my mistakes reorienting
and moving forward again if you can do
that you're actually going to get
results and nothing is more hopeful than
results step number one have a goal make
it specific make sure you know the rules
of the game you're playing make sure you
know what a win looks like in fact that
may be the most important question that
you could ask yourself the most pointed
thing that you can determine in your
life is to know what does it look like
to win once you know what it looks like
to win then you can work backwards then
you can figure out what you need to do
to score then you can figure out the
skills that you're going to need in
order to get great in order to go out
and dominate in order to be better than
anyone that has ever come before you but
to do that you've got to know what your
goal is and once you have that as Dale
Carnegie said if you want to conquer
fear don't sit home and think about it
go out and get busy so now you have your
goal now you're telling people what
you're going to do now you're telling
yourself who you're going to become and
it is terrifying to me how people can
pacify themselves with a sense of
accomplishment simply by having a goal
so let me tell you right now the thing
that separates the people who Dream from
the people who execute is a willingness
to act and at the end of the day nothing
is going to stop you not fear not
inability not inadequacy the only thing
that will stop you is failing to start
you've got to find a way to get yourself
going you've got to find a way to take
that desire that interest in you and
turn it into a raging Inferno something
that's going to get you moving and going
ahead that will trample everything in
its path once you're able to do that
nothing and I mean nothing will be able
to stop
here is a reality no matter how
successful the person is that you're
looking at and wishing you could be like
them and thinking that they have
everything all figured out the one thing
that I can promise you is that all of us
struggle on the inside that is just a
reality of The Human Condition once you
understand that that is a reality that
that's just a part of the human
condition then you can begin to ideally
let yourself off the hook and that
you're not spending a lot of time
um stuck there but to give you a
specific example from my life the
biggest one the most harrowing one that
I went through was in film school so uh
to cut a very long story short I went to
film School believed that I had innate
talent I went into film school with a
fixed mindset I did very well at the
beginning of film school and that all to
me felt like it was proof that I was
right that I was naturally gifted that I
was a born Storyteller and that I was
going to go and have an illustrious
career here and I actually went through
a fascinating period in film school
where I was both terrified that secretly
I wasn't good enough and but at the same
time actually believed that I was
naturally gifted and this is what I was
meant to do and every bit of feedback
that I got in either direction was
it made me believe to the core of my
being that it was true so when I would
do something poorly I would think see
that part of me that was convinced that
I actually don't have talent you were
right and then I would do something well
and the part of me that believed that
was like see I knew it you were born for
this and it all came crashing down as I
worked my way up the ranks at USC Film
School
um only four people are chosen to direct
what's known as the senior thesis film
or a 480. and I was one of the four
people picked and I was like see I knew
it man I'm born for this of course I got
picked to do one of the senior thesis
films that just makes sense I'm I'm that
good and I thought okay cool the thing
that makes the thesis film so important
is the film School pays your budget to
make this film so at a time where
there's no YouTube there's no iPhones
like filming is an expensive Endeavor
here you've got somebody that's paying
for it and that becomes your calling
card to the industry so George Lucas
famously made one of these films and
obviously we know how his career ended
up working out and they showed us his
480 by the way and it was amazing it was
amazing and so you could see that here
was this gifted filmmaker and so I have
that in my head like look at George
Lucas this film's absolutely brilliant
he's gone on to have this brilliant
career I'm gonna make an equally
brilliant film or maybe a little more
brilliant and then I'm gonna go become
the next Lucas or the next Spielberg and
I'm going to take that film and get my
three picture deal
and I proceeded to
run smack Bang into one immutable truth
and that was that I wasn't a talented
filmmaker
and I don't say that to be humble I say
that out of truth because I didn't have
the skill set to make a good film once
the level of complexity had gone beyond
a certain level so I had thrived in
these really short really simple films
and then once you're talking actors and
dialogue and you know the things that
would come close to what we would
recognize as a normal film uh I had no
idea what I was doing and
try and try as I might I couldn't figure
out how to make the film come out well
and it didn't come out well and I was
mortified and I was embarrassed and I
never wanted anybody to see that film
and I was really and truly devastated so
I want you to imagine your whole life so
what I graduated at like 22. so from 12
to 22
all I knew was I wanted to be a
filmmaker and my whole life was moving
towards that and it looked like I had
the natural gift and of course if you're
going to be an artist you're either born
with it or you're not right that's all
anybody said I can't express enough in
the 80s and 90s when I grew up when
people talked about art you either had
it or you didn't and that was that there
was no sense of growth mindset Carol
dweck had not written the book yet and
so it wasn't even like I knew there was
a growth mindset and a fixed mindset I
just knew you're either born with it or
you're not
the great news was I was born with it
here we go it's going to be amazing and
then boom I can't do it and I realized
oh my God I wasn't born with anything I
don't know how to do this there is a
tremendous amount of process to this art
and I don't know that at all but of
course as I'm in the middle of it I just
think my world has come crashing down
I'm not gifted I will never be gifted
and therefore I will never be a
filmmaker I will never make anything of
myself and just it was a downward spiral
of epic proportions
and at the height of that I would go
home from my dead-end job and I would
lay
face down on the carpet because I
couldn't afford furniture and
literally just sit there I can still
feel
that cheap nylon carpet and the way that
it felt on my face as I laid there
thinking well
my life is effectively over certainly
the
my life that was working towards a dream
is over
and
now it's just about finding a way to be
the smartest person in the room
and if that means that I have to go and
work a dead-end job to be the smartest
person in the room then that's what I'll
do and so I used to go and interview for
jobs having nothing to do with film
because I felt totally broken and
my goal was to at some point in the
interview have the interviewer say
you're so smart why are you interviewing
for this role and because I had a fixed
mindset and I so needed that praise from
the outside I was putting myself in
these super weird and useless positions
just to get that little nugget of oh my
God like you're so smart
and I had to put myself in sort of worse
and worse company to get to that point
and
finally and I don't remember what it was
that
led me to this idea of brain plasticity
but somewhere in the depths of my
despair I realized
can we get better maybe we can and so I
started reading about the brain
and that started to plant seeds in my
mind that maybe brain plasticity was
real and maybe I could get better and
just because I wasn't good at film today
maybe I could get better at film down
the road and I ended up getting a job
teaching film because remember those
that can do those that can't teach so I
felt like okay well I can teach this
even if I can't do it and then so
between reading about the brain and
realizing wait a second
if I work at this thing I actually get
better my brain actually changes and I
become better at something and
given you know having gone through
however many years of schooling I'd been
through I started thinking about like
wait a second you would come into any
class and the funny thing is as a kid I
remember every grade just being
absolutely terrified that well I did
okay of being a fourth grader but Mom
I'm going to get devastated as a fifth
grader I don't know what I'm doing and
no matter how many times my mom would
console me and say remember they're
going to teach you how to learn the
things that a fifth grader needs to know
they don't expect you'd already know it
it just wouldn't sink in and so I was
sort of back in that moment of you know
I don't know how to do this
but maybe
my mom is right maybe the
neuroscientists are right and maybe I
can learn
to become that thing I want to become I
start teaching film and as I'm teaching
it I realize wait I'm helping my
students become better filmmakers so if
I can help them become better filmmakers
and brain plasticity is really true then
I could get better as a filmmaker myself
and that that realization changed the
rest of my life and this is why I am so
obsessed with the idea of
a growth mindset and brain plasticity
because the biology backs it up and once
you understand it's what I call the only
belief that matters the only belief that
matters is that if you put time and
energy
into getting better at something you'll
actually get better your diet is one of
the most important things you can do to
boost your energy your focus and your
productivity what you should be eating
varies wildly and I will just tell you
right now that while I'm gonna give you
a very simple thing that you can follow
and it's going to take care of 80 of all
of your desires and problems know that
there is massive variability at the
individual level and that you should be
testing a lot of different things to
find out what is right for you so what
I'm about to lay out is the sort of
generic strategy that I think everybody
should try but getting into the
nitty-gritty is going to require you to
do a lot of testing there is no way
around this I wish that dieting was more
simplistic but based on your lifestyle
based on your heredity based on your
microbiome all of this stuff is going to
dramatic to dramatically vary so be very
thoughtful make sure you run
experimentation having said that what
are the things that I think are
Universal number one you want to be
eating Whole Food whenever humanly
possible so you want to eat food that is
recognizable from what it was in nature
so a piece of meat should look like a
piece of meat it shouldn't be highly
processed your vegetables should look
like vegetables I mean you should be
brushing dirt off of them that kind of
recognizable from nature nuts should be
I mean ideally raw I'll be really honest
I do sometimes eat roasted nuts but if
I'm honest that's worse than if you're
just eating them raw so you want things
that are as close to their natural state
assumingly possible the less that they
have been messed with manufactured
altered in any way the better off you're
going to be I will say that heat is
something that I apply to virtually all
of my food there are some really
interesting theories about from an
evolutionary standpoint that cooking is
one of the things that allowed us to
grow the big brain because by cooking it
you not only soften the food make it
easier to chew but you also release some
of the nutrients beyond the scope of
this to get into that but when I I say
raw I don't mean that everything needs
to be uncooked I just mean the less
processed the better things that I eat
every day I eat a lot of eggs red meat I
eat some chicken a bit of pork but I'm
eating a fair amount of meat so I get a
good portion of my calories from that
again individual variability if you're
doing a vegan thing word I'm totally
about it test for the individual
response that you get I find that the
more plant forward I go there's like a
breaking point where I start feeling
worse could be me it could be me doing
it poorly but as long as you're doing
whole food I think you're on the money
so eating whole food and making sure
that you're avoiding sugar that is like
the big thing so I don't think you can
eat fruit with impunity I think you have
to be very thoughtful about that if
you're unsure of what fruit is going to
impact you and how I highly recommend
getting a continuous glucose monitor
that will allow you to eat fruit if you
want and see what kind of glycemic
response you have for instance I find
that I can make certain fruit smoothies
and if I eat it slowly enough my glass
response will go up to about 120. I
prefer to keep it in the 80s but hey if
it goes up to 120 and it's sort of even
and it comes back down I don't consider
that too problematic but if I eat it
really quickly and it spikes up to say
140 150 that to me is problematic and I
don't want to be that high so you can
play with things also what you put in
the Smoothie Etc if you're going to eat
fruit and vegetables make sure that you
separate fruit and vegetables keep those
two things distinct I think you will
find by wearing a continuous glucose
monitor that you're going to have a
dramatically different response to most
fruit than you will to vegetables again
there's a lot of variability here so the
more that you test on yourself the
better but that's really the the sort of
generic response if you're a generic
setup that I think everybody should try
Whole Food whenever humanly possible
avoid sugar keeping your blood glucose
below 100 I highly recommend it for me I
try to keep my glucose in this the 80
ish range that's sort of my default I
also do intermittent fasting I think
that that is very effective getting into
things like autophagy is beyond the
scope of what we're talking about right
now but even that I think is going to be
huge body composition is greatly
affected by intermittent fasting again
individual variability make sure that
you experiment with this stuff for
yourself I do when you average it out I
think I went about 18 months where I was
tracking every day my average over that
extended period of time was 17 and a
half hours so on the weekends it's it's
shorter but on the weekdays sometimes
it's longer sometimes it's 19 20 21 22
hours that I'll go between meals but
again over a very extended period of
time it averages out to 17 and a half
hours of not eating now the way that I
do that I have my last meal around 1 15
definitely done chewing by 2 p.m and
then I don't eat again until the next
day at around 9 9 30 somewhere around in
there shorter on the weekends longer
during the week and it it balances out
I'm having everything from green leafy
vegetables like bok choy uh collard
greens kale broccoli
um two carrot jicama I do occasionally
have some sweet potato it'll be a little
thoughtful about that one watch your
glycemic load that definitely spikes me
more than green leafy vegetables but
those are the mix that I use again I'm
eating Whole Foods virtually all of my
calories come from Whole Food during the
week in fact I'd say 95 of my calories
come from Whole Foods it's very rare
that I deviate from that but doing that
allows me to have tremendous focus a lot
of energy get the most out of my
workouts maintain my body composition
keep my fat low keep my glycemic spikes
low so I'm not getting you know blood
sugar spikes which helps me maintain my
energy through the day and also just
from a longevity standpoint I think
that's a great idea I will say go look
at David Sinclair he's got some pretty
compelling information around the fact
that Meats may not be great for
longevity so while it makes me feel
awesome that's something called mtor so
be thoughtful as you get into the the
complex weeds of this stuff nutrition is
a very big complex topic again the only
things that I consider universals are
whole food and reducing sugar universals
close to a universe will be intermittent
fasting though some people can have
differing responses to that so be
thoughtful as you experiment with this
stuff but if you do that like I said 80
plus percent of your problems are going
to go away that's a nice low
inflammation diet and keeping your
inflammation low is incredibly important
what I learned long before I actually
became successful was that success
wasn't going to change my insecurities
and I think most people go into it
thinking that success is going to
eradicate their insecurities they look
at somebody that's successful with this
admiration and they think when I'm that
successful I will look at myself with
that admiration and it doesn't work like
that so and what's super interesting
it's not surprising at this point this
would have surprised me in my 20s but
like I said thankfully I learned these
lessons when I was still struggling
is that you know your insecurities are
going to go with you wherever you go and
the name of the game is really about
skill set and skill set in a few
different ways skill set in there are
things that I want to accomplish in this
world and I must get good at them but
then there's also skill set in managing
my own mind and that that is the the
real juice so
um you gave me that poster outwork
everyone and when I was writing a
message on it it's like
to outwork everyone there there is a
certain thing that must be true in your
mind which is you have to know that all
you have is this moment and so success
is not something in the future where you
will cross a Finish Line and feel
forever the way you've always wanted to
feel which is what people think
success will feel exactly like this
moment whatever your life is right now
if you and if it's a mess I could give
you a billion dollars and it would still
be a mess and so understanding the name
of the game is really to optimize the
way that you respond to your environment
the way you respond to your challenges
the way you respond to difficulties
that's it there really are only two
macro level motivators that we have in
life and that's Pleasure and Pain and so
what I want people to understand is okay
so if nature only gave you two things to
motivate you Pleasure and Pain why would
you eliminate half of them and so most
people think that life is about avoiding
the pain I'm here to tell you right now
in a very controlled fashion it is about
really experiencing the pain learning
from it so Ray dalio the most successful
hedge fund manager of all time has a
perfect math equation pain plus
reflection equals progress if you don't
feel the pain you never reflect on it so
my thing is I spend eighty percent of my
time focused on the beautiful things in
my life the things I'm grateful for the
beautiful things that I want to bring
into existence all of it 20 of the time
though I'm in the darkness man I'm in
that Tim Grover Relentless I'm going to
make this happen if I have to break
myself and I'm not afraid to lean into
that because I know how powerful it is
now if you really want to put numbers
how powerful this is they did a study
and they wanted to find out what happens
how can we get people to endure more
pain and the punch line is hilarious so
they would take people and they would
submerge their arm in a bucket of ice
and they would just hold it there as
long as you can now at first it's just
cold but after a while it really starts
to hurt and so people would end up
yanking their arms out
they found that people could hold their
arm in the bucket 35 percent longer if
you let them display anger
so put it in they get to that point
where they're about to pull it out and
you tell them yell cuss do whatever you
need to and they'd be able to do it
they're the expression of intensity even
what I'm doing right now I can feel
myself ready right I'm ready to strike
my muscles are tense I've got a
different posture I bring my chin down
there's intensity in my eyes like dude
I'm now feeling that because I'm I'm
embodying it right so it makes me really
feel that and so I actually started to
tell the story earlier I hate the gym
but what I would do to make myself work
out is I would my wife would be on the
opposite side of the gym and I would
stare at her and I would imagine her
being attacked and I would imagine her
being attacked by people bigger than me
and that the only way that I could fight
them off is to get stronger there was
nothing beautiful in it I was not
worried about Aesthetics I was worried
about saving my wife and by stepping
into that dark place and because people
are like what are you doing yeah but
dude that was I needed that motivation
to push past what I want to push past
pain boredom all of it and just to
really get into it and get a result but
I find that people shy away from that
look to me it's an 80 20 split if you're
spending more than 20 of your time there
it will be corrosive yes it will start
to erode your sense of self because
you're going to feel badly right because
I would be saying to myself you're weak
come on like you've got to get stronger
if you spend 80 of your time doing that
that sucks yes I don't want to live like
that right but not being able to dip
into both you'll just never hit the
level of extraordinary you may be fine
you may even be good yep but you're
never going to be great being an artist
right now this is like the best possible
time to have something that you can do
by yourself that you can improve on by
yourself that's ultimately going to have
real world consequences for you when we
get to the other side of this so here is
and and something tells me that if
you're playing professionally you
already know this but here is the the
reality about greatness greatness is
about doing the things that are
tragically boring and that you have to
repeat over and over and over to get
better at them in a deliberate way you
don't just want to repeat them blindly
but in a deliberate way buckling down
and doing the things like for a musician
playing your scales practicing your
improvisation practicing your cold
reading all of the things that are very
easy to put off when you have a job and
you're busy and you're making a living
it's it's kind of like typing what they
find is most people sort of their their
typing rate if I remember rights like 65
to 70 words per minute is where most
people tap out but I think the record is
somewhere around 250 correct words per
minute so if the average person is
tapping out around 65 but the Delta is
all the way between 65 and 250 you begin
to see like how far you can really push
yourself but people get to a level that
they deem acceptable and they just sort
of stop there but because everybody is
being forced to shut down right now if
you're a musician and you're saying look
I'm not worried about streaming and
going live and all of that which I think
there's a whole question to be answered
about doing that and about how you can
could generate even more Revenue by
going online but you asked me to set
that aside so I'm going to set that
aside but right now is that chance to
embrace a level of boredom that most
people are not willing to push through
in order to get to Greatness so in a
business context I always tell people
boredom kills more entrepreneurs than
anything it kills more entrepreneurs
than fear most people they just can't
slog through sucking at something and
sitting in the discomfort that you get
from doing the things that you're not
good at long enough to get good at even
those things so that you can truly go
out and create art because I don't think
you can create real art until you've
mastered the basics to the point where
as Bruce Lee said you don't think kick
you just kick
and I love that quote there's another
Bruce Lee idea which is I Don't Fear the
man who knows 10 000 kicks I fear or I
don't fear the man that does ten
thousand kicks one time I fear the man
that does one kick ten thousand times
and that is this moment and if you can
take this down time and let go of how
good it feels to perform I have to
imagine a big part of the reason you got
into this and that you did all of the
work when you were younger to get good
is because you love performing so much
but right now that's basically off the
table
so if in this moment you can buckle down
be disciplined set your sights on
something very specific that you want to
get good at disciplined practice at that
thing to get good at this on the other
side of this you're going to be far more
extraordinary than you were when you
went in because you no longer have the
distractions of the actual performance
you can just get down to practicing so
flip that switch in your mind and think
all about coming out the other side of
this a beast an absolute monster better
than you went in and if you can tell
yourself that story I'm committed to
this I'm willing to do these things that
other people aren't willing to do and
put in the practice and understand as
you're going through that unimaginable
boredom that on the other side of this
is a skill set that has utility
then this becomes an extraordinary time
but if you keep telling yourself the
story that so many others are telling
which is this is you know a time of
deprivation it's um just lamenting that
you're not able to perform and all the
things that made you love music in the
first place then just because you're
repeating that it becomes a dark time
focus on the other side and you will get
through this amazingly once you accept
that the thing that separates you from
the rest of the animal kingdom
is an unimaginable ability to become
you have an unimaginable ability to
become something
in 2014 private companies averaged eight
percent annual growth
after I went into my partners and I said
I quit
and I'm gonna go do something that makes
me feel alive they were totally shocked
and I got all the way to my house and I
was on the phone with my wife I did it I
had been unhappy for so long
and I said I did it I told him I quit I
gave back the equity here I am and I'm
pulling into the driveway at my house
and my phone rings
I miss my partners
they say come out to dinner with us
out of respect and love I went out to
dinner with them
and they said the now famous words
we could do this without you
but we don't want to
and that gave me what I needed to
connect to something other than money
it reminded me of the Brotherhood it
reminded me that I had fallen in love
with these guys as human beings that
there was something more than money
there was something more than being a
clever marketer
that I remembered for a second who I am
the things that make me unique that I
have a desire to connect that I actually
enjoy communities that I'm not a guy
with a Killer Instinct I'm not
interested in stepping on my cons my
competitors next that's just not how I'm
wired I'm wired to build something I'm
wired to see people shine I love seeing
other people win I think it's incredible
now that doesn't mean that I don't want
to win I want to win at the absolute
highest level I want to be the greatest
of all time
I want more people to write about me
going to Mars because they're terrified
to try to match my intros
I want that right and I hope each and
every one of you wants to play at that
level I hope each and every one of you
looks at the greatest of all time and
says if I'm willing to break myself and
have to get there I could do it
but being honest with who you are being
honest that if there's something else
that you want to bring to the table that
you find a way to do that and so I said
guys I will come back and work with you
on one condition
I will never
prioritize money again
my highest value in business is
camaraderie and at the time that was
sacrilege we had made it pact with each
there was three of us the three of us
had made an actual pact that we would do
whatever it took to make our technology
company more profitable and if that
meant skipping a family vacation if that
meant waking up at 2 A.M on a Saturday
to meet and brainstorm we did it both of
those stories are real we did things
like that I would go away with my wife
for Christmas to see her family in
London and I would literally take a
camera with me so I could watch
the company
back in La I've never switched off I
didn't take days off I was working no
matter where I was I was working seven
days a week I didn't take a real
vacation meaning that I wasn't actually
working while we were on it for six and
a half years one I believe doubt is a
gift let me say that again I agree doubt
is a gift man if you know you're going
to do something that you will stick with
it you're not afraid to Pivot or change
directions whatever but that you know
you're going to go after the things you
care about you're gonna go after them
hard and you're not going to stop when
you get tired you're not going to stop
when you get bored you're going to stop
when you when you're done like when you
know that about yourself then doubt is a
gift and so man I actually wish more
people in my family would doubt me at
this point my family they don't doubt me
externally like they don't vocalize it
they may all doubt me like crazy but
they don't do me the kindness of letting
you know exactly so the reason that that
is a gift is because I believe that
human beings are wired to leverage two
different things one the beauty of what
you're trying to create the people that
support you and love you and want to see
you succeed like that's amazing that
feels good it's going to give you energy
and I think you should spend eighty
percent of your time there
there are times however
especially when something gets really
hard really painful that and and I've
talked about this before but if you're
doing a research on pain tolerance the
one thing that they know universally
will allow somebody to tolerate more
pain is anger
actually expressing anger so if you put
somebody's arm in a nice bucket make
them hold it there like At first not so
bad but then it really gets to the point
where like this hurts and when it gets
to the point where it hurts if you want
something like 30 percent longer if you
let people go
and like really Express like anger and
rage they'll be able to deal with that
30 longer so there is something you're
able to Marshal the body's resources
when it gets really hard so in those
moments that's when I turn to the people
that hate on me that want to see me fail
the doubt that I can do it like and use
that in that aggressive dominant way to
really push through and like under no
circumstances will I let that person be
right so that's incredibly powerful now
the second part is they're doubting you
so much that it's beginning to hurt your
own mind so now here's the thing one if
somebody is chipping away at your
ability to believe in yourself you need
to distance yourself from them now this
gets really hard when it's family but
it's absolutely critical to me like if
my family were bringing me down with all
the love and compassion in the world I
would let them know hey I can't be
around this level of negativity so we
have to come to an agreement either
you're just gonna stop
like keep it to yourself or I'm going to
have to spend less and less time with
you so let me be very clear with the
Rules of Engagement are I love you like
let's really make it hard mom
I love you Mom I love you more than you
can imagine I love being around you I
want to spend time with you but the
things you're trying to do to protect me
because her intentions almost certainly
are good the things you're trying to do
to protect me are actually eroding my
confidence I would not words like this
these exact words okay this is the exact
conversation that I would have with my
mom so it's beginning to erode my
confidence confidence is one of the most
important things that anybody needs to
cultivate if they're going to go on to
be successful so I fully understand that
you only have my best interest at heart
that you really want to help me and you
want to make sure that I don't make a
mistake that can be very detrimental to
my life and my career and where I'm
headed so I understand that those are
all really really beautiful intentions
but they're having this unintended side
effect so because of that I either need
you to stop or I'm gonna have to spend
less and less time with you which would
be utterly heartbreaking for me so let's
agree to disagree let's agree that when
we come together that we're going to
talk about positive things beautiful
things wonderful things and then if she
can't help herself stop spending as much
time with her it's that simple it's not
easy I get how painful that would be but
you have to and when she then calls and
it's like you don't come around as much
anymore you say we had the conversation
I was brutally honest with you what I
need to protect my self-confidence I
know that you don't mean to do it but
you're still doing it I can't be around
it so until you can figure that out and
let me tell you all the times where you
were saying this out of the other and
again
I'm not questioning your intentions I
know your intentions are good because
that's immediately where she's going to
go but I'm just trying to protect you
like I say the same to God they're not
really negative why are you taking them
negatively this is your fault you can
hear words like that and so you just
need to be abundantly clear I have a
line in the sand I love you of all the
empathy and compassion
but I'm not gonna be around that so and
then as you distance yourself she will
change her behavior or she'll entrench
if she entrenches you know everything
you need to know about her mindset
that's toxic whether it's your mother or
not and then if she doesn't entrench and
realizes whoa like even if I believe to
the core of my being that I'm not being
negative those things are perceived as
negative and that's one thing that you
can say that'll lighten the load hey
maybe those things really are positive
but just so you know I'm interpreting
them as negative they're affecting me at
a visceral level as negative so for me
to keep coming around they have to be
excised from our relationship period
simple
[Music]
yo I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Alex from Mosey
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I still make more
money than them there has to be
something else one of the things that
grinds my gears about a lot of people
that I see on Instagram that you
probably see too is this whole like no
one can outwork me Mantra first off it's
objectively false because many people